fun fact the idea that actually started
this Jake Paul film Theory athon didn't
have anything to do with Jake at all it
had to do with those insane faze clan
and clout clan houses they showed Nick
and Elissa living in and Shane series
did you see those monsters that both
mysteriously had the same Hollywood sign
piled into the pool that's like the face
house and then it struck me as an
unusual coincidence
Shane never looked into it so I did a
little digging myself the houses which
we actually found the addresses for our
part of a complex of four mega mansions
all built by a Los Angeles real estate
mogul and builder who never designed the
houses to be lived in by real people no
they were always designed to be party
houses or celebrity rentals for movie
sets his signature style was including
features for what he called the douche
huazi like colored lighting glass
everything and of course that signature
Hollywood signed by the pool and if you
think Jake's old neighbors had it rough
apparently the neighborhood hates these
eyesores and have complained for years
that the noise and people coming and
going into the house ruins the area if
you'd like to pick him up off the market
the asking price for all four on the
developers web site is a cool 50 million
dollars which sounds like a lot but
actually for the size of these houses
and their location is made of a steel
faze clan and Klout gang lived there now
which I thought was kind of an
interesting coincidence in the series
that they would both live in these
bizarrely identical influencer houses
like some kind of digital
like so until I learned that basically
both clans are the same because they're
both owned by a company called w8 media
they're set to live in those houses
until at least 2020 and I know this
because I inquired about the next time
that the houses would be available long
story short I win this year's dreamy 4
creepiest internet stalker and I just
really wanted to fit this in somewhere
because it's interesting but it had
nothing to do with the main points of
the other episodes that I'm doing in the
series so now you know hello Internet
welcome to film Theory the show that
isn't about spilling tea it's about
sipping tea while applying facts today
I'm continuing to follow in the
footsteps of Shane Dawson by exploring
all the issues that he didn't in his
tell-all series on Jake Paul or at least
all the issues that he allowed Jake to
just dismiss you see during Shane
Dawson's documentary we come to some of
the final moments of the docu-series
when Shane finally finally sits down
with Jake during the conversation Shane
rightfully brings up a video from the
channel nerd city who's done a pretty
darn thorough job of researching Jake's
history when it comes to merch openly
claiming that Jake is exploiting and
manipulating children by Hawking merch
to them in every single video out of a
13 minute and 50 second video nearly
seven minutes of that time is devoted to
advertising products it's an interesting
video and another fun fact here Shane
may have just been inspired by it when
he was brainstorming names for the title
of his Jake Paul docu-series inside the
mind of Jake Paul in response to these
allegations Jake doesn't really have
much of an answer he just vehemently
denies that he could possibly manipulate
children calling the claims ridiculous
and that he wants people trying to make
the connection to just shut up and say
here's the thing though Jake and yeah
I'm talking directly to you in hopes
that you do end up watching this I'm not
gonna shut up about this it's important
for you to understand why what you're
doing is wrong and not just wrong to
little kids but also illegal and also
against YouTube's ad policies so even if
you don't care about the kids who watch
you do it for that billion-dollar
business
hoping to build up cuz guess what
nothing kills a business quite like a
class-action lawsuit by a bunch of angry
parents oh yeah and I know you don't
like teachers nothing my teachers taught
me in school
do I utilize in my day-to-day life don't
worry even though we're covering a lot
of educational stuff today
keep it interesting for you they I wish
my teachers did teach me I mean millions
of your own dollars are at stake after
all now it's important to note that
merch itself isn't the problem here and
that a creator isn't wrong to promote
their own products if that were the case
I'd be the pot calling the kettle black
having to do my own series on the
manipulation of Matt pats because by the
way new game theory and film theory
merch is launching on November 24th and
it looks great there are hoodies and
reversible jackets and socks and holy
crap why am I not getting in trouble for
any of this
while our favorite blonde punching bag
is well it's because this isn't a kids
show whereas the Jake Paul channel is
but Matt Pat I'm not doing a kids show
I'm faking pranks with my friends and
fake getting kidnapped by clowns and
doing up shots of girls climbing ladders
and close-ups of my dad kissing girls
and covering up videos where I use
racial slurs Jake yeah I know I hear you
and I get it I know I wouldn't let my
kids watch yeah but let's look at what
defines a kids show
the media's official definition of
children's programming is a show that's
aimed at 6 to 11 year olds with a few
key hallmarks one it can be animated or
IRL 2 it often contains comedy and
slapstick humor 3 it's designed to
entertain and not to educate and 4 it
doesn't contain open cursing Jake you
meet all four of these criteria in
spades you have an animated character
you feature plenty of slapstick humor
you are certainly not educational and
you beep out any cursing and one look at
videos from your live tour show exactly
who's watching you what do you like so
much about Jay Paul you even have
several members of your team under the
age of 10 with the youngest being four
for a more cynical person would assume
that you're using those kids as a means
of adding audience surrogates into your
crew kids who younger viewers can
project themselves onto and that you
just happen to own 20% of their future
business but media definitions and
audience demos don't even
because you yourself are intentionally
trying to target these kids my audience
is definitely younger I'd say it's like
eight years old so like 16 years old so
now that we've established that you have
a bona fide Kids program on your hands
or at least that you wanna have one then
what's the big problem well there's
nothing wrong with a kids show where
people do a bunch of stupid things but
there is a problem with a kids show that
breaks a bunch of regulations regarding
advertising you see psychological
studies have shown time and time again
that young children are unable to
understand when they're being sold to
for instance in a 2002 study by Oates
blades and günther of the eight year
olds that were tested fewer than half
understood that ads were meant to
persuade them to do something for
instance if I threw Batman on screen
right now and did this attention kids
it's me Batman
the Joker is attacking at Gotham City
needs your help give me your age name
and mom's credit card number so I can
stop it do it and you could be a
superhero just like me well we all know
it's just me doing a bad Batman
impression but to developing kids they
can't understand that that's not Batman
and that that could be someone taking on
the mantle of Batman lying to them and
in the effort to rip them off it's not
their fault either you can't write it
off as stupid kids our brains just
develop that way up until age 7 children
exist in what's known as a pre
operational phase where a child is only
able to focus on themselves they can't
really hop into someone else's brain and
understand that that other person might
think or feel differently than they do
it's like Twitter but actual
eight-year-old children and not people
acting like it your own children so win
any children's program someone says this
these are such like high quality nice
elastic because these sports bras are
absolutely amazing wearing something
that like actually means something in
like minds you have been positive
reminds you have been happy these kids
are just physically unable to process
that your shorts won't be able to help
them achieve their dreams
unless of course their dream is to buy
merch from a company who doesn't do
returns on a lot of its items and
doesn't do cancellations after 20 hours
or less than one day after purchase mom
and dad better figure out that jr. stole
their credit card in a hurry because of
all this the federal government started
to
down on children's advertising in the
80s before that time kids programs
primarily only existed as advertising
tools for toys or products think
Transformers he-man and street sharks
because there is no other reason why
street sharks should have existed in
short Jake any of your advertising to
children would have been totally legal
in the early 1980s and if laws against
children's advertising weren't around
today
all the kids shows on TV would look a
lot like your vlogs but now because of
these regulations FTC now requires that
any advertising happening around these
kids programs one have a clear
distinction between the program and the
commercial to that the main character in
the show doesn't sell the products
during the show and three that products
can't be integrated into the program's
content only have 24 hours to enter this
competition if you get yourself
someone's already competent camo
collection checkout mini Jake Paul
rocking these mini J oh so cute gun fans
Wakko backslash dick Paul and I get
yourself a baseball jersey and
sunglasses lucky for you Jake you're on
YouTube so those TV regulations don't
apply BOTS YouTube also has a pretty
clear advertising policy for anything
qualifying as kids content and it's here
Jake buddy where you're not doing much
better for yourself I'm actually gonna
show you the policy not because I want
to bore you to death but because in your
Shane interview you seem really
unconcerned with how these sorts of
policies could affect you I don't see a
problem with it at all like just because
my fans are younger does that mean I'm
manipulating to read from YouTube's ad
policy for kids which they implement for
any kids between the ages of 6 and 11
quote your child may see an ad intro
followed by a video ad marked with AD
before the video you selected Oh
paid ads undergo a rigorous review
process for compliance with our policies
paid ads won't include any click
throughs to websites or product purchase
flows this means that when you have a
show for kids there should never be a
link in the description to buy merch or
in the end screen or an eye card or
anywhere no clicking on stuff to go to a
website that's going to sell you
something or promote a product this kind
of promotion to children between the
ages of 6 to 11 is forbidden by YouTube
according to the rules set forth in
their kids app YouTube disables these
kinds of links for children because
again it was children being much more
easily manipulated than adults and well
for lack of a nicer way of putting it do
what they're told by the character that
they idolize that's you Jake all while
being told that Jake Paul errs are
unique push the boundaries and are
totally edgy by wearing their merch
every day bro
then there's YouTube's requirement that
short animated messages appear before a
paid ad to help a child understand that
the paid ad will be played clearly an
effort like on TV to try and help
children distinguish between the show
that they want to be watching and the ad
that they can skip to go get a juicy
juice refill but in your content there
is none of that division there can be no
after these messages when your whole
vlog is practically the message or 50%
of your blog according to that nerd city
video out of a 13 minute and 50 second
video nearly 7 minutes of that time is
devoted to advertising products but I
wanted to give you a fair shake Jake
because in this nerd city video he just
showed one example so maybe he was just
cherry-picking what video he showed so I
cast a bit broader of net across the 20
random videos that I selected if some
were almost entirely advertisements like
this one don't watch this with your
parents really inspires confidence
through that title where no less than 65
percent of the video was dedicated to
selling your underwear while others like
don't watch this with your parents yeah
they have the same title only in this
one his girlfriend isn't in her
underwear nearly as much contained only
about 15% of the run time as promotion
and then you had videos which had almost
0% promotion sure they contained really
uncomfortable transitions from we're
supporting a march for gun control to
here's my girlfriend taking off her
shirt
the matter how old you are doesn't
matter you know if you don't think you
can get involved or make a difference
you can do at home can make a difference
baby get better every single day help
the world every single day smile every
single day yo let's March but next to no
promotion so yeh overall on average when
looking across all twenty videos merch
and other promotional pushes took up
between twenty and thirty three percent
of his videos
certainly not the 50 percent mark that
nerd City said but still over the
regulated limit allowed in children's
programming it also limited how many
minutes per hour of commercials that
children's programming can contain that
17.5 percent and 20 percent of the watch
time maximum so Jake you're actively
producing a self-identified kids show
that openly shields to kids who aren't
mentally mature enough to understand
that their ads in turn breaking at least
two major federal regulations around
children's advertising as well as
YouTube's general guidelines for ads
aimed at children but you know what Jake
US Ohio boys have to stick together I
will proudly wear my hometown pride
merch that I just got for the low low
price of $10 I mean at this point of
Cameron returning I know this whole
Shane Dawson thing was just an image
rehabilitation for you so here let me
give you a scapegoat to pin this all on
since like PewDiePie's apology video
taught us number two what you want to do
is shift blame shift blame whatever you
could do okay if you're taking
responsibility and that's omitting that
you're wrong remember the last episode
where I talked about the fact that you
aren't really a youtuber that you're
just a cog in your own corporate machine
well that means that there are a lot of
other parts in that machine cogs in that
machine who should know better much
better many of your investors hold a
slew of investments across the media
landscape I mean don't get me wrong
these guys have done some awesome work
and funded companies that now help
millions of people
everything from nest to Spotify but they
are huge names in the entertainment
world there is no way that these
powerhouse investors don't have a basic
understanding of children's advertising
laws and didn't do their due diligence
on you and your
content before giving you that small
loan of a million dollars here's the
thing by funding you they are implicitly
supporting your business decisions
including marketing directly to children
whether good or ill if Jake Paul is in
their portfolio and presumably a
significant portion of Jay Paul's
revenue is coming from his merger then
they are potentially recouping their
investments on the backs of illegally
manipulated children and believe me that
is not a good look for anyone so Jake
what's it gonna be you want to be a
famous social media businessman but that
means taking the blame for this yourself
or are you gonna pass the blame off to
your investors who should have known
better and should have been guiding you
away from your business practices but in
doing so it means they're gonna have to
give up some of that businessman swagger
that you're so proud of choice is yours
and here's the last thing I'll say about
this issue yes
I wish Shane Dawson had pressed Jake
more about this but honestly I don't
think he could notice the weird editing
around this particular series of
questions and only this series of
questions it's like it's ridiculous I so
you spoke your truth on that we should
respect
sentence is oddly cut off full cut at
the end of it and even Jake's responses
felt different here than they did for
the rest of the interview so I've been
doing that my whole life so like for me
really trying to say like I'm just doing
it to manipulate and try to make money
over kids like it was almost like Shane
was getting into territory that Jake
were the people pulling the strings
behind Jake decided to remove from the
table but it does beg the question
should it have been in there should he
have pushed harder does Shane have a
moral responsibility to include stuff
like this in his documentary and
ultimately what does a documentary need
to contain in order to be a documentary
do Shane Dawson's docu-series actually
qualify are his race and expose is doing
more harm than good
is the Shane Dawson documentary format
dangerous I could talk about it now but
then how would I extend this to a part 3
of this theory so make sure you
manhandle that subscribe button
tell him Jake give it a little bit of a
headbutt a little bit so that way you
know in a couple days when the third and
final part of this theory goes live and
remember in the meantime that's just a
theory a film theory and cuts
[Music]